[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 153 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Melanie Warrick and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hi mark
hi Melanie we were changing things up a
little today we are changing things up a
little today so it was a really rough
week last weekend if this is our second
time at doing this because it really hit
us hard a lot of things that played out
last week so we decided today as a
change of pace we're going to talk about
some different organizations that you
can donate to if you are feeling the way
we do because I know both of us have
felt very angry and sad and all kinds of
things don't me of all the things I
think the thing that comes to my mind is
when I talked to our mutual friend KF
and she says she's in a mood you think
that's an appropriate way to describe it
yeah we do have our interview for the
week we have Tony Yuto who is gonna talk
to us about basil and so we will talk
about that and then we're gonna end it
and we'll we'll talk on some of the
up-and-coming stuff the cool things of
the week but as I mentioned we do want
to recognize a lot of the things that
have played out last week and it has
impacted us in our own ways so if you
want to take any action and especially
if you want to donate to different
causes that can help people who are
disadvantaged
it's my nice couching word for all the
things there's a couple of different
groups like time's up now which is a
Legal Defense Fund that's a place where
survivors of sexual harassment or abuse
in the workplace can get the legal help
and public relations support they need
to take back their power suggest us and
make their voices heard
there's also project alloy or also known
as alloy Alliance and they give
financial grants and other resources to
people who are early in their career
underrepresented and tech and this is a
way to give them financial resources
especially to go to conferences and go
to events that allows them to get access
and network within the industry and find
opportunities and then there's the me to
stem which provides resources to
graduate students postdocs and women who
have been hurt by sexual harassment and
so that one is definitely a very
valuable resource that's just up and
coming and so these are all options if
you know of others feel free to tweet at
us actually yeah it'd be lovely I want
to give mark you had a few others
especially in relation to what happened
over the weekend yeah with the recent
shooting in Pittsburgh at the synagogue
to mention hias which is a Jewish
organization that helps refugees
worldwide of any ethnicity basically
rescuing people whose lives are in
danger and basically being who they are
so if you are able to Nate to it of
course like that there's also the
anti-defamation league which is another
retreat organization that had been
fighting anti-semitism and hate since
about 1913 worldwide if you are looking
for say a visual or gathering for for
the shooting that happened in Pittsburgh
they do have a map and schedule of those
that are right there on the website yeah
the other thing I wanted to mention this
is something that matters a lot to me in
particular is there's very established
well-known AI academic conference or
machine learning academic conference
however you want to view it and they do
all the things in the research space
around this neural information
processing systems we've talked about
this conference in the past they did
this whole research this past year and
came out with results last week on
whether they were going to change the
name of the conference because nips as a
acronym has been very much viewed as an
offensive acronym because they've chosen
based on their research to not move
forward with that which many in the
community feel disappointed and many
other feelings around this one of the
wonderful advocates in the space and I'm
so bad at pronouncing names but anima
anand kumar who is the director of
machine learning research at Nvidia
she's also burn professor at Cal Tech
she has started a petition that we will
link and if you want to help show your
support please sign this petition and I
think mark you wanted to say yeah things
just wanted to say you know it's been a
really rough week for Jewish people it's
been a really rough week for transcend
non-binary people there's been several
things around women's rights that have
also have happened and sexual assault
there was bombs being sent to people
yeah I mean it's been a really rough
week
please take some time for yourself if
you need it like get any self help or
self care that you need to take take
care of yourself take care of your loved
ones you have people in your life that
you love tell them as I think we were
talking about before like sort of life
is a bit fleeting sometimes so make sure
you take care of yourself in the people
around you definitely and I'm also going
to make this plug again that if you're
in the u.s. please vote absolutely what
we are gonna do is transition back into
our regularly yep let's go to a program
old programming and so we will go and
talk to Tony Tony thank you about basil
so let's go do that sounds great so I'm
very excited today to have tourney i
youto do
today the engineering lead for bezel
product excellence to talk to us all
about bezel how you doing today Tony I'm
good thanks how are you guys doing well
don't what it's Wednesday it's Wednesday
it's Wednesday no it's Thursday it's
Thursday there we go
you're right you're in Thursday we're on
Wednesday clearly that I don't this
country has gotten much bigger I don't
know what day it is cool today
well I remember this today we're gonna
talk about bezel that is the thing we're
gonna be talking about you are correct
yes but before we do that Tony why don't
you tell us a little bit who you are
what you do what do you do here at
Google you know Google for about 10
years I'm working a variety of things
and was was he using blazed the
predecessor of basil for a long long
time and I switched over to the basil
team recently to try to get a handle on
making it a quality open-source product
so I sit at the intersection between the
engineering team that sees it as an open
source project and end users who really
don't care
provenance of it they just want
something that all works together with a
certain level of wry ability and polish
and so that's that's my role in they're
trying to bridge that gap
great well so Tony I know you're here to
talk to us about basil what's basil ok
basil basil I was gonna say my
Australian ok yes well well our logo
before the the stylized cubes was really
a basil plant ah and half our team is in
New York half is in Munich so we get
both pronunciations but so I'll accept
either everything's good but the origin
of it is it sprung from Google's and
kernel build system which was called
blaze and basil is an anagram of blaze
in that sense blaze started about 10
years ago probably 12 at this point
years ago at Google and we've been using
it for all our builds during that time
and it's gone through a series of
iterations and rewrites from Python to
Java and added this extension language
at one point we decided to open source
it and
make the basel project sort of giving
back to the community and we're finding
it's a it's a whole new bit of work to
do that now that sounds right so like at
a high level what is what does the bezel
actually do that's the thing it does it
is a at a very high level it's a build
system like really make with Auto tools
or or C make or Gradle or maven but
blase is a different focus from the
ground up and that we want to be able to
build across multiple languages and
orchestrate very large bills and run the
tests for them in a very repeatable way
our focus is on fast and accurate and
pictu we want to do incremental builds
at speed that requires having a very
well-defined build so that we know
exactly what to build incrementally and
then we can tie basil into systems to
get remote build execution and caching
of results so that we can really make a
team faster by reducing the time it
takes to do their bills cool in terms of
basil basil what what makes it different
though from other options that are out
there at the bottom the key is all of
our build steps are hermetic we always
know what goes into something and what
comes out of it essentially we hashed
the inputs to any rule and an - the
resultant thing so we can cache it very
well you don't see applications you know
that you include a dot H file and it
will get it from somewhere that doesn't
happen in basil buildings you always
know where you're getting all the inputs
to your build
so that tactical strategic decision at
the bottom allows us to get reproducible
builds and very precise incremental
builds and then you don't get let's say
with make based things and shell scripts
gluing stuff together we also build all
the languages at once so we don't have
to change build systems in the middle
filled your native code for an Android
app with one set of tools and then
bundle that up and then use let's say
Gradle to build the java parts so how
many languages does it actually support
that's a good question if there are
probably around 40 rule sets that we
track right now some of them are on the
basil build site
a github project there others are
independently developed but you know the
big ones are C++ Java Python code
JavaScript c-sharp and net scale uh
there's dart and Kotlin and swift and
rust and Ruby two others I haven't even
named an orthogonal to that we talked
about platform support so we want to be
able to build in any of those languages
and then deliver to docker kubernetes
order different execution platforms one
of the other important basil
distinctions is that we separate the
notion of the platform you're building
on from where you're going to deploy it
so we were very clear in the semantics
said well I happen to be building on a
Windows machine code that's going to do
deployed on a linux server or an android
phone
great well as a developer how do I use
basil what does it look like when I'm
working with it it's not too different
than other things you're used to we have
build files which are equivalent to a
make file or a Grail configuration or a
seem a [ __ ] stock text inside it or a
bunch of definitions of targets we don't
really have executable code in the build
files we want them to be very
declarative rather than procedural so we
define targets and each one is the name
of it the sources that go into it and
the dependencies it has from a
developer's point of view they sprinkle
the build files around whether their
code and we'll run blaze Builder blaze
test with a things happened is it is it
bezel build or is it blaze build or you
know yeah you have historical Freudian
slips that happens on the team all the
time but it is Basile build more blaze
build if you're inside Google the
differences between the products are
minimal and we're trying to eliminate
them each day advantage is hard to
unload now that's really interesting
though so if I'm sitting down for a new
project am I thinking to myself I'm
building a polyglot project so maybe I
will lean towards basil because I have
multiple languages is that like a
contributing factor to why I might
choose this as a tool it could be yes
one of the things we find talking to
people is you find people from a
community like the goal community they
have
wonderful set of tools for building pure
go systems but once you start mixing it
with other languages and you want to
share let's say a proto buff definition
between your go and your C++ code then
the pure go tools fall short I don't
mean to pick on go this is true for
every language that has a very
well-defined set of development tools
once you start crossing over to
multilingual things that's where blaze
really shines because the single set of
build definitions can define your entire
product and you don't have to glue
together different systems and some sort
of shell script or make file which is
the or make file write make file the
call Gradle to call make gluing together
is always fun though we'd love doing
that but it's hard on your release an
engineer's exactly great engineers love
that don't they well I know we talked
already a little bit about this but like
why would why would we choose this over
something like make maven Gradle
whatever really to reduce the cost of
your development what the goal is right
you don't want to switch to another
system because it's looks nicer you want
to do it because you want to make your
lives your developers lives better by
giving them a faster turnaround time and
we do that through this the fact that
each build step is a hermetic action so
we know that we don't have to do it
again a second time change one file in
the basil build and we will only rebuild
those things that absolutely have to get
rebuilt we have capability to hook into
caching on let's say site-wide basis so
that all your developers at one site can
share each other's results so if you've
all pulled down a common bit of
third-party code the first person who
builds it loses for the team they
they've waited everyone else gets to
reuse the object module that your
teammates incurred the cost of building
so everyone goes a little faster it's
the incrementality good reliable
incremental builds the speed every one
up we do the same thing on the test side
you change one bit and instead of having
to rerun 10,000 tests we may only have
to rerun 20 and you know you do that for
enough developers enough days and it
turns into real money that sounds really
interesting from the perspective
it seems like you know in today's
today's development environment you're
no longer like pushing at a jar you know
we're just pushing at a binary like
you're you're compiling some code and
then maybe bringing in another library
and putting that in say a docker image
and then taking that image and doing
stuff with that this sounds like this or
a tool that sort of provides like the
glue between like the seven different
things that you kind of need to pull
together would that be accurate
yes exactly we're not entirely there yet
but you should be able at one point to
define a role to build a docker image
and list inside that things that were
built in different languages all
assembled multiple binary is going into
that with a single blaze build basil
build the target place and pay so it's
easy to go back and forth between those
exactly to keep them straight but I know
you guys are probably so used to it at
this point it's pretty common that
you're just like yeah 11 years worth of
muscle memory and and they're an anagram
of each other and if you're slightly
dyslexic it's impossible well so Basel
supports R I'm going to just switch
between the two
no I'm kind of enjoying going puzzle I'm
in Basel another so Basel supports
remote execution does that mean I can
parallel eyes my workload across lots of
machines yes absolutely even on a single
machine we try to paralyze it a bit in
that your build builds a graph of what
needs to be done and then after the
graph of what's needs to be done is is
computed we know exactly what execution
steps need to happen and the ones that
don't depend on each other can be all
done in parallel on a single machine we
may only spin up for maybe 10 threads
worth of that because we don't want to
deadlock your own machine but with a
good remote execution environment we can
easily spin up 3 400 threads of things
that can be executed in parallel to
actually the remote build protocol is
published and a standard we have there's
some third parties working on things
that use this remote build protocol
their own kind of build farms Google has
a product it is alpha testing and it's
in you can assign up to try it right now
where we provide remote code execution
but someone could build their own remote
build server there are some early Basel
adopters who have their own strict
requirements about no
off Prem so they want to build their own
remote executors that their code never
has to ship across the wire and they can
keep it in-house these were all possible
and they can use basil to take advantage
remote build even without using a
third-party cloud product so it's doing
research on basil and we talked a bit
before about all the languages it
supports it looks like some of that
support comes through extensions or
there's some kind of extension mechanism
there like how does that work one of the
key differentiators between the Google's
version of blaze and the new version of
basil is that rules used to be built
into the blaze execution blaze binary
they are all in an extension language in
Bazzle one the extension language is
called star LARC now it used be skylark
and that has been renamed for reasons
and there's a very strict separation
between what a developer order at the
high-level season a build file and the
rules that are written in this extension
language star lark is Python esque it
looks very much like Python when you
write it with a few restrictions we
don't allow recursion it's got a very
similar syntax and at this point I
should mention one of the things that
helped make basil accurate and it's its
view of what we have to build every
command to build our testings is done in
three phases where we load up the things
you need and all the roles which is
really just parsing and doing things
like visibility we can restrict certain
targets in the build to a particular set
of other targets so that you can them
just like in any language you would do
some object wrapping to hide
implementation details we can hide
targets from having everyone in your
organization exploit the or use the
things you don't want to be seen that
happens at load time analysis time is
when we can execute these star lark
rules to determine what our build graphs
should be and we can determine the delta
from the last version of the build graph
so we know what has to be built new and
then finally we get to an execution
phase where we can paralyze like crazy
to do only what we need in the shortest
time possible
and the strict separation also prevents
this loop where the results of an
execution can feed back into analysis
later on I'm sure everyone listening has
had a project somewhere where you run
the make twice in a row and you get
different results because the first time
leaves crossed that the second time
picks up and that just doesn't happen
with basil based products so what kind
of I mean we talked about language
extensions but what kind of stuff do
people build with extensions what would
people want to do with that all of our
rule sets right now well C++ and Java
are still built into the basel core a
Python a bit too we're moving it out
rules go is all built in the extension
language to the JavaScript the c-sharp
support called Len is built an extension
language really the Basel team and the
larger basil community and outside
companies are all contributing the sets
of rules that really make the basil
ecosystem bigger than the core basil
product itself and so as a company as
well who has a team of developers like
we could write our own extensions that
would help us do specific things that
are particular to our companies as well
we can take the haskell rules in
particular there's a company in France
queeg I hope I'm pronouncing it right
who have done a lovely set of rules for
Haskell because they needed it for their
daily development and they contributed
it back to the outside world so they
have other people using their rules and
it requires no modifications to core
Basile itself great what do you enjoy
most about what you work on well I've
been building and selling developer
tools for years and it's super
gratifying to go into a place and have
engineers say oh I use this it makes my
job easier that's really what I love
about what I work on and I believe in it
too because Google I've shipped products
that were consumer side and we really
care about the provenance of what goes
into our code and I think most product
shipping companies do they have to know
everything that went in and they didn't
accidentally include GPL code and a
product that's not compatible with that
or if they did use an LGPL library they
linked it dynamically rather than
statically and that's really
- no with many ad-hoc built systems but
with Basel you can actually trace down
the provenance of everything you've
included and then script your own
checking against that to make sure that
you know what you are giving to people
and that's that's really one of the
things that motivated me to move from my
last team to the Basel team so what
products are actually using bezel right
now I'm guessing this probably a lot of
Google products that probably use
battles little to open-source well all
Google products for the most part are
built with the internal version called
blaze and most of the reason for that is
that internally we have some different
packaging requirements you know if we
were shipping to a Linux system someone
might want a Debian or RPM package
Google has its own thing that's
different from that it's not that it's
secret is just our way of doing things
and there's no benefit in sharing it
with the world no benefit to the rest of
the world if we tried to share it so the
Google version of blaze is built on
basil with a few internal additions so
really all of Google products are using
basil there are I can't list customers
directly but I can talk about recent
basil con we had a few weeks ago in New
York we did have nearly 200 external
attendees representing a hundred
different organizations either currently
using basil or evaluating it right now
from large multinationals to small
startups and some organizations who are
very tight-lipped about what they do but
I can say is we've found a real niche in
organizations that worry a lot about
compliance and read certifying what they
are shipping and they love the fact that
they can test extensively and accurately
and know the provenance of everything
they've got into so financial
institutions really like people doing
embedded devices that go into various
consumer price products love it as well
for that reason but I that was a good
answer
what are resources in ways that
developers can get started with basel
going to
our website dazzle dot build and looking
at one of the starter quick starts for
various languages there's full
documentation of the product I say
product because I'm the product guy but
of the project and what the features are
there is a discussion group basil
discuss on Google Groups and all the
source is available on github I wouldn't
recommend that as the place to start
figuring it out the website is the right
place but the github project does
contain many of the rule sets that are
built by the community so just looking
through that gives you an idea of the
kind of support you can expect where you
don't want to adopt Bassel excellent
what cool stuffs coming in the future
what can people expect from bezel well
we're here o point right now we want to
get to a 1.0 release in 2019 and we
haven't announced the firm 8 yet I
understand this well yes deliberately
vague deliberately vague it's not fit we
are done at one day was gonna last for
five years because the origins come on
new rule sets develop but the big thing
in ways basil one that will be a
stability promise and a way to inform
users well in advance of changes that
might be incompatible and breaking so
that they have a long time to migrate
and it's very easy conceptually to
figure out how to migrate to newer
versions but we also want to bring the
rule owners into that because when we
have scholar roles depending on the Java
rules and they each depend on basil it
does the community no good if the
scholar rules and Java rules each are
built to depend on a different version
of Basel so we want to get the community
behind sort of phased releases so that
end users don't have any surprises and
that's that's the big guarantee for one
dot oh the rest of it is more usable
documentation removing old knits that
we're built-in Google long ago and have
been carried further and we should have
killed off so we're trying to get those
out of the project now while we still
can
and then more rules that's a more
language support the short term future
for pencil yes that sounds really good
Tony thank you so much for coming on the
podcast with us is there anything else
that we didn't cover you wanted to touch
on before we go
not too
I pointed you to all the things people
can find us in the places I mentioned
you we're on a slack Channel
periodically slack group is called basal
build I think we can share a link to
that but cool - hard to say offhand so
we can get it onto the website I enjoyed
being here and had fun today cool
well yeah Tony thank you so much for
spending time today with us and hanging
out in the podcast and answering all
that questions yes thank you you're
welcome
good afternoon thanks again to Tony for
joining us this week and especially
thanks to Tony for joining us to the
last minute we had to fill a spot very
quickly and we really appreciate you
taking the time and giving us such
interesting information about the puzzle
project and the open source backing
behind it the reasoning in the history
yes so when we initially were putting
this together mark and I were struggling
with like cool things of the week
because we were in a bit of as I
mentioned earlier a mood yeah but we do
have some cool things of the week and I
do want to take a minute to recognize
that which is why we are recording this
the second time around
this is officially marks third year for
the podcast we're at that point so you
and Princess started this high franceska
high friends asked I'm saying you and
Mark you shall try to but yeah you are
at your three-year mark which is
incredible and this is a hundred and
fifty three podcast that you have worked
on with one exception because I did
without you there's a few so maybe it's
150 total for you yep but still three
years long time amazing what have I done
I don't know what you've done
yeah close to two million downloads at
this point so I'm gonna go and give that
one away
yep just want to give you a big kudos so
thank you people should tweet at you or
say something to you as congrats if
you're out there listening been quite a
ride that never stops never does you can
never never stop but thanks to everyone
who's listening for that time period as
well I couldn't be possible without the
audience participation in the audience
listening so thanks to everyone who who
listens and we love it when like we get
messages people wander up in there like
oh my god you the people from the
podcast sometimes they even remember my
name but it's been amazing the community
that's listening the other thing we
wanted to note that we realized we'd
forgotten about it's Halloween on the
day that this is being real
yeah it's true it's a Halloween in the
States which i think is now infiltrated
like the rest of you world I've been in
Japan wants for Halloween that's pretty
impressive you like dressing up and
eating candy please go ahead yeah so
hopefully you're having a good time and
you're having some fun ooh I'd like to
see people's costumes so yeah those are
the two things we especially wanted to
mention we do have a couple things on
GCP york did you want to yeah let's
let's go into the actual cool things of
the week for the GCP side so there are a
few new and interesting announcements so
there's the new asset inventory system
that's available if you're responsible
for managing basically your
organization's cloud resources maybe you
have lots of projects with a different
app engine stuff in it with different
building account storage buckets etc
trying to sort of consolidate all of
what you have and like manage that all
can be actually kind of tricky and hard
so we've started this whole thing called
the asset inventory system that provides
an API that will enable you to do that
if you actually have a look we'll put a
link in our in our blog post but there's
examples there of how you can hit the
API it is the first pass there's going
to be some more stuff coming so
definitely check it out if you do manage
those kinds of very large workloads and
then one of our colleagues said Fargo
has written up a post on introducing the
cloud kms plugin for a hash e-court
vault and so hash cart vault is an open
source tool for secrets management it's
very popular with many of our customers
and so the cloud kms vault users can
manage their cloud KMS keys now
encrypted decrypt data and sign verify
data using the familiar vault API
there's a number of features and
benefits that he's shared like familiar
API is authentication and authorization
and privileged ciphertext upgrades and I
don't know exactly what this is but FIPS
140-2 level 3 certification so I'm sure
it's good I'm sure it's important yep
something to do around encryption and
decryption so yeah you can check out the
post and see what that's all about yeah
it looks pretty easy to set up I can't
post which is great speaking of
teammates our friend from last week
Mountain Oh Amanda cloud developer
advocate continued his series on civilus
from the ground up and they've done a
really neat job where in what they're
doing is connecting a spreadsheet to
their document management system and
make you basically making a Google Drive
spreadsheet the UI for how you interact
with the system which is really nice for
business users agreed and then not a GCP
thing but
I'm gonna give a shout-out to myself
which is I just posted a blog I haven't
done very many lately about
understanding cybersecurity for previous
generation so not the next generation
but the previous generation because I
know many of us are probably tech
support for our parents or grandparents
and so understanding some of the things
that you need to keep aware of to help
them stay safe online and well include a
link in the show notes as we do with all
the other things I'm gonna send my
parents this is really good
well great you can also read it for you
to help with your parents that's the
goal I actually wrote this down because
I was like even though you and I are not
sports fans I figured we should give a
shout out to the Red Sox which you know
it's kind of a thing for for them
especially to be winning the World
Series which is wonderful and I just
want to give a crap yeah baseball yay
okay cool so they won the World Series
this last weekend where are you going
what are you up to I'm gonna be at an
unconference no no soaked mole at the
end of November and what about you
November I'm gravitation for bit yes
good December I really need it yeah
December I will be speaking at cube con
which I'm also very excited but I'm
happy for you going to cube con Marc I
think that's it for us this week yeah so
Melanie thank you for joining me for yet
another episode of the podcast thank you
I thank you all for listening and we'll
see you all next week
[Music]